good evening we begin the program with
breaking news on the covid pandemic the
first official analysis by uk government
scientists has backed up studies showing
people with the omicron variant are
significantly less likely to develop
severe symptoms
but experts at the uk's health security
agency warn that high transmission rates
could still lead to a significant number
of people needing hospital treatment and
their early data also suggests any
protection offered by a booster jab
could wane within 10 weeks
the results of that study were published
as a record number of daily coronavirus
cases were confirmed in the uk with
nearly 119
789 new infections reported in the last
24 hours
let's bring in our science correspondent
thomas more good evening thomas so good
news
on the severity of illness less good
uh on the rapid spread and the waning
immunity yeah overall i would say this
was qualified good news mark so
if you look at some of the results that
uh
have come out from the uk health
security agents did today uh they show
that people with omicron are uh 30 to 45
percent less likely to go to a e than
those who had delta
and 50 to 70 percent less likely uh to
need to be admitted to hospitals so it
fits with other research showing that
omicron is in fact causing mild disease
which is clearly good news there are a
couple of really important uh qualifiers
though the first is that there were just
132 patients in this analysis and also
that they were by and large young under
the age of 40. there weren't many over
the age of 60. they're the ones who are
much more likely to go to hospital so
the the agency says there will need to
be another
round of number crunching in the weeks
to come i think the other really
interesting uh data that came out from
the agency today is on the booster as
you mentioned and that shows that 10
weeks after you've had the jab your
protection against symptomatic infection
uh drops by 15 to 25
now they say that most people are
between eight to ten weeks after uh the
booster at the moment so there's no
immediate concern and also they believe
that protection against serious disease
the kind of stuff that would lead you to
need in hospital care would hold up for
longer and at that moment they say
there's no need to rush into a decision
to give a fourth jab which is already
the case in israel
yeah i was going to say
the waning immunity
issue looks important but
you're saying at the moment i mean
israel have gone for the fourth jab some
other countries are now considering
considering it
you're not hearing anything along those
lines at the moment no so the joint
committee on vaccination and
immunization is keeping a very close eye
on this and there's every possibility
that in future you will be in a
situation where you would want to give a
fourth jab particularly if
um some of the modelling that's come out
today from the university of warwick and
the london school of hygiene which shows
that you know we could be seeing cases
well into the spring well if that does
happen
then there will be significant numbers
of people who may well be seeing a drop
in their immunity and you will be at
that stage where you would be thinking
once again to begin this round of
booster immunizations that sweep through
the population but we're not there at
the moment
okay thomas thank you very much indeed